MARK: YOU BET.
LELAND: WE WILL DIG IN
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS IN A
MINUTE.
SAD MILESTONE IN CORONAVIRUS
FIGHT, THE AP NOW ALERTING THAT
MORE THAN 200,000 CONFIRMED
DEATHS WORLDWIDE FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS, THAT’S ACCORDING TO
JOHN HOPKINS RESEARCHERS THAT
ARE KEEPING TRACK OF THIS.
NOW WE DIG INTO THE ECONOMIC
DESTRUCTION THAT’S BEEN CAUSE
BID THE CORONAVIRUS NOT ONLY
ARNOLD THE WORLD BUT
SPECIFICALLY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE BRING IN THE LABOR SECRETARY
EUGEN SCALIA, WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE, THANK YOU.
DIG INTO PROJECTIONS BY THE CBO
THAT CAME OUT, Q1, 14% WHICH ARE
OVER, Q2, 16% AND Q3, 11.7%.
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE AS GILLIAN
SAID THAT THINGS ARE GOING TO
GET WORSE FOR PEOPLE BEING LAYED
OFF.
>> WELL, WE RELEASED AT THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT SOME DIFFICULT
NUMBERS THIS WEEK TOO SHOWING
THAT NOW MORE THAN 26 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE LAST 5
WEEKS.
THAT’S JUST HARD TO SEE AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE SACRIFICE THAT ARE
-- THAT’S BEING MADE BY SO MANY
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
BEAT THE VIRUS AND WHAT MAKES IT
EVEN MORE PAINFUL REMEMBERING
HOW STRONG THE ECONOMY WAS A
MONTH AND A HALF AGO.
WE JUST HAD AN EXCEPTIONAL
ECONOMY WITH RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT AND RISING WAGES
AND THE MISSION NOW IS TO GET
BACK THERE.
I DO THINK THAT A SILVER LINING
IS HOW WE GOT HERE.
THIS WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE, NOT A UNDERLYING
WEAKNESS TO THE ECONOMY AND I
THINK WE HAVE TIME NOW TO GET
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE AS WE
REOPEN.
LELAND: THERE’S A LOT OF WORRY,
THOUGH THAT THE RESPONSE TO THIS
IS GOOD HEARTED AND WELL-MEANING
AS IT IS IS PUTTING IN SOME
FUNDAMENTAL WEAKNESSES TO THE
ECONOMY, THE CARE’S ACT MEANS
STATES CAN EXPAND BENEFITS UP TO
13 WEEKS, 600 ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ON 30
WEEKS ON TOP OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS YOU’RE GETTING FROM THE
STATE AND STATES ALLOW TODAY
PROVIDE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY FOR
REIMBURSING EMPLOYERS.
I’VE TALKED TO A NUMBER OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO SAY THIS IS
BASICALLY INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE
TO STAY ON UNEMPLOYMENT ROLE AND
MAKE ECONOMY SLOWER.
IS IT TIME TO TAKE --
>> THAT’S WHAT THE CARE ACT DID.
LET ME EMPHASIZE, LELAND, YOU
DON’T GET UNEMPLOYMENT IF YOU
QUIT WORK BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
GET THAT UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK.
YOU NEED TO BE LAYED OFF AGAINST
--
>> LELAND: I UNDERSTAND.
>> ONCE THE JOBS BECOME
AVAILABLE TO WORKERS WE AT THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT EXPECT WORK
TOASTER LEAVE UNEMPLOYMENT AND
GET BACK TO JOBS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE STATES TO HELP --
LELAND: YOU’RE NOT WORRIED THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING MORE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT THAN THEY WOULD
BACK WASHING DISHES OR
LANDSCAPING WILL STAY ON
UNEMPLOYMENT, THEY WILL TAKE
LESS MONEY TO GO BACK TO WORK?
>> WE ARE KEEPING AN EYE ON
THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STATES UNDERSCORING FOR THEM THE
IMPORTANCE THAT AS WE REOPEN
THEY TAKE A LOOK AT EMPLOYERS,
HEY, WE ARE READY TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK AND WORK WITH THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS.
I ALSO DON’T THINK IT’S GOING TO
MAKE SENSE FOR INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS TO PASS ON A JOB FOR A
EXTRA COUPLE OF MONTHS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS TOO.
WE WILL KEEP AN EYE ON IT.
MEANWHILE WE FINALLY GOT THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
REFUNDED WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT
I THOUGHT WAS SO IMPORTANT.
WHAT IT DOES IS PROVIDE LOANS TO
SMALL BUSINESSES KEEP WORKERS ON
PAYROLL, AGAIN, LELAND, AS WE
REOPEN THE WORKERS ARE READY TO
GO.
I WAS SAD --
>> LELAND: REAL QUICK, I WANT TO
GET TO LAST POINT.
THIS WAS BETWEEN 2.5 TRILLION
AND $3 TRILLION THAT’S BEEN
SPENT SO FAR ON THE CORONAVIRUS
HANDOUT, BAILOUTS, CALL THEM
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY, THAT’S
A LOT OF MONEY.
IS THERE A TIME WHEN WE WILL
HAVE TO START THINKING ABOUT HOW
MUCH ALL OF THIS COSTS NOT JUST
SPEND IT WHEN BECAUSE THIS IS A
CRISIS?
>> TWO QUICK POINTS, LELAND.
ON PAYCHECK PROTECTION, THAT’S A
GOOD PROGRAM, I’M GLAD IT’S
BEING FUNDED AGAIN.
I WAS SADDEN TODAY SEE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP DELAY THAT
FOR A LITTLE BIT AND I THOUGHT
DURING THAT TIME SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS THAT
WEREN’T GETTING THAT SUPPORT
THEY NEED.
LOOKING FORWARD I THINK YOU’RE
RIGHT WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL AND
PART OF WHAT GAVE US THE VERY
ROBUST ECONOMY WE HAD WAS A LACK
OF UNNECESSARY BURDENS,
RESTRICTIONS, CONSTRAINTS ON
BUSINESS.
FREE MARKETS, FREE AMERICANS ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE REBOUND TOO
AND AS WE LOOK TOWARD ANY
POTENTIAL FUTURE ACTION OUT OF
CONGRESS, WE NEED TO AVOID IT
BECOMING A FRENZY OF NEW
OBLIGATIONS, RESTRICTIONS AND
THE LIKE.
WE NEED TO LET OUR ECONOMY COME
BACK TO LIFE.
LELAND: AN IMPORTANT QUESTION IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE RECOVERY IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE AND YOU JUST
POINTED OUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT MIGHT INFLUENCE THAT, AS WE
LOOK AT CBO NUMBERS, THE
DISCUSSION OF THE V-SHAPE
RECOVERY WHERE THINGS WILL SNAP
BACK WHEN EVERYBODY REOPENS,
THAT SEEMS FEASIBLE AND PERHAPS
EVEN REALISTIC WHEN EVERYTHING
WAS GOING TO SHUT DOWN FOR 15
DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
WE’VE BEEN AT THIS FOR 45 PLUS
DAYS.
IS THERE A REASON TO SET
EXPECTATIONS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS
RECOVERY IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE?
>> IT’S UNCHARTERED TERRITORY.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS THIS HIGH BUT, ON THE
OTHER HAND, WE HAVE NEVER HAD
THEM TAKEN AS PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE.
THERE WAS A POLL YESTERDAY FROM
AP SHOWING THAT 78% OF AMERICANS
UNEMPLOYED EXPECT TO RETURN TO
THEIR JOBS.
I REALLY LIKE THAT NUMBER, BUT
YOU’RE RIGHT, LELAND.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE VERY
FOCUSED NOW IN THE REOPENING SO
WE CAN RECONNECT WORKERS TO JOBS
WHILE THE JOBS ARE STILL THERE.
LELAND: MR. SECRETARY, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON A
SATURDAY.
I KNOW YOU A BUSY DAY OF